you're somewhat in touch with the
Italian side of your heritage because
someone's a way that you you drive
around in LA on a Vespa do I I went to
Italy with my wife I saw these guys
these Italian men riding on the Vespa
they look cool beautiful hair sunglasses
you know relax that a stop sign just
drinking an espresso I gotta get one of
these there's a little espresso holder
on it yeah I thought it was fabulous
don't wanna come back to LA I go I got
to get a bus but I didn't know in LA
it's a law you got to wear a helmet now
I got a big head so I had a double XL in
the helmet I don't look good on a Vespa
look like a Martian right you got that
giant marshmallow head yeah
no no guard just my face and there's no
espresso here you will you might get
murdered at a stoplight now we have it's
really dangerous we had one of the guys
on our show
Jordan's Lansky's with the producer here
he rode around in on a Vespa here in LA
and he's fine but this place wasn't
built for Vespas so he was like a
hipster riding around and then some old
lady just hit him and he went flying and
his Vespa went into like 65 pieces and
that's over he doesn't he doesn't drive
the best but anymore
that guy Jordan slansky yeah is more
time than I am yeah we we do segments
with him and we they go out online and
everywhere I go people say is he for
real and I'm like I think we have a
picture of him sadly this that guy's
read oh yeah yeah yeah great but where's
the goddamn wheat yeah I know there's no
that's why he's never really made it
he's never made it no wheat you don't
get anywhere you're not in
you